I greet you warmly my name
is dr walter ziegler i wrote
this book series
great thinkers in 60 minutes for you and my students
simply because it is important to me
to once again present the core ideas of the most important philosophers in a
clear and understandable way
philosophy is something  very, very
wonderful she asks the most important
questions why am i here
what does it all mean how
does society work the history of
mankind if you
look at the whole thing from the stone age, the
simplest beginnings to today,
the question arises where does it go  everything to
where does the story end and above all
what can or should the individual
person do in his life there is
something like a task the philosophers
give the exact answers
the problem or one could also say
the fascinating thing about it is that the
great philosophers  give very different
answers and I have only
ve  In the book series big thinkers
in 60 minutes I tried to present the core thoughts of the
respective thinkers
using the most beautiful and important
quotes and I asked what use
this thought is for us today, namely for
our personal lives.
all these thinkers ultimately
asked the question what is it what  the
world holds together at
the core with platform it is the idea of the good that
e open our souls to the good and l
arn to see with the inner eye with
arx for example it is the work
o the way we work
nd produce as well
s  individuals and society as a whole when
we go fishing in the caribbean, for example
, we feel very different
than when we work in the factory under capitalism
,
so he can say that being
determines consciousness and
he derives the entire historical
historical development from the work at
freud  it the libido or the
sexual energy whereby libido is far
me  hr as sexuality that also refers to
love for mother love for
children love for science with
a yes and happy says well this love
shaped society and the
individual we can bring it to bear we
can suppress it we can
sublimate it and we can  living them out
with hegel it is the world spirit whereby
world spirit of course does not mean
that god sits above and watches us as
we plow on earth
no the world spirit for hegel is,
so to speak, the entirety of
social development and
individual development first charles
darwin of philosophy  so he says
everything is in motion we are only children of
young adults and that
individual development also occurs within
the framework of epochs as human
development from the simplest beginnings
civilization continues to progress
and this self-movement that is
the world coming into its own  ghosts so an
interesting idea in nietzsche i  is it,
for example, the will to power because
yes we can take we want we
can habermas at habermas
language is important through communication
language itself and the
desire for understanding inherent in language
the whole of humanity comes
closer together
so that is his great vision and
so basically every philosopher has a
phenomenon from which he tries
to understand the whole world
that can be the work that can be
sexuality
that can be the language and
interestingly they
not only explain the world to us but they say
something within the framework of it  world explanation could be
our personal task
and that's the exciting thing about it yes you
see i try to bring
you closer to the core idea of a philosopher in every single volume the only
uestion that remains is the question i'm oft
en asked if you're inter
sted in philosophy with which philo
opher should  you start
and I can only say it
doesn't matter in the end  n each of these great thinkers has
undoubtedly struck a spark out of the
crystal of truth,
it only remains for me
to wish you much happiness